[Music]  I've started having these memories  memories of other lives other  possibilities other worlds the Nazis  encouraging American history a new  America near zero things are getting  very dangerous there could be a war what  the hell is going on  ever heard of the men in the high gasm  the fascist can be beat it's in our  hands  this can't be true one it is there are  other possibilities  what if they find out who you are  we need to wake people up the only hope  any of us had  [ __ ] addicted to this thing their  machine the Nazis are building to invade  and conquer they allow words  you can either embrace your destiny  Dodgers  [Music]  the enemies of the garage are everywhere  there's the men of the high castle I  believe in her she's give me something  like a fight floor  [Applause]  we can  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you